الحي الثقفي في قطار استطب جماهير كره
القدم لما له من ابعد ثقافيه متعدده
[تصفيق]
هنالك جذب صوت الاذان المشجعين فدفعهم
الفضول عند كل نداء للصلاه لمشاهده
المسلمين كيف يصلون وكيف يتم النداء الى
الصلاه من خلال رفع الاذان
زوار المسجد عبر عن سعادتهم وشعورهم براحه
والامان وهم يرون المصلين يؤدون شعائرهم
الدينيه
واشعر بالامان
خدمات جليله تقدمها كتارا للزائرين حيث
يقوم موظفون باستقبال غير المسلمين
والاجابه عن اسئلتهم واستفساراتهم وتقديم
شرح مبسطن بطريقه اداء الصلوات
من الناس يهتمون بهذا ويقدون وقتا بعيدا
عن كره القدم ويعيشون تجربه بعض الثقافه
القطريه وكان لدينا الكثير من الزوار هنا
في مسجدك تاره
كاس العالم ليست كره القدم
وفهمي كيف يعيشون وما هي حياتهم اليوميه
عاليات دور هام في تقديم صوره حقيقيه عن
الاسلام وحياه المسلم والتعريف بالثقافه
القطريه من عادات وتقاليد وغيرها